Russia Unleashed one of Its biggest
missile attacks on Ukraine so far on
Friday Killing at least 18 civilians and
wounding dozens more several regions
were Hit including kev nepro laviv
odessa and zaparesia the latter is Home
To A nuclear power plant and has been
The ongoing Focus of  Conflict as
russians Target Ukrainian infrastructure
Ukrainian President vladimir zelinski
says the majority of the missiles were
Shot Down however
Well, I woke up at 30:30 from such a
terrible sound and that was how
terrible the sound was, the missile was flying and it was just
buzzing and making noise, I didn't know what to do
I wanted to run down to the shelter
and I think I will run into the bathroom. Well, I
run into the bathroom. And I
just have a mirror, how much the mirror
flies away, that if it had been a minute, not even a minute,
it was a second, I would probably have been
cut. We went down to the subway and
stood on the platform.  and felt a very, very
strong vibration Somewhere, even two vibrations, yes, they
felt a vibration that
fell through the escalator. I don't know that there
was a lot of dust that fell there, and it was
very scary, there was a strong explosion, and as of
now, including the
provision of assistance with the participation of
local self-government bodies and  of
our volunteers,
rescue operations are ongoing to search for people,
including those who have disappeared so far.
This is mystali
s yes such a group that is targeted
Apollo Hello, this is a shopping center there
is nothing nearby Well, it is an entertainment center, but it is
targeted I was in the house, it was
banging Thank God we didn't touch anything there,
but it's
great, more than 10 Shaheds attacked
Lviv, Lviv region, quite a lot of
rockets  Well, I myself counted more than five
rockets, the information will be more accurate,
we have one dead person, 18
people received injuries of various types of
complexity. Well, there are large destructions,
about 18
houses were destroyed in terms of windows, doors,
everything flew out, that's more than 2,000 windows, three
schools, one
kindergarten,
pass